bill gates right now just said we could
have been following the advice
in january in january the world health
organization to whom you are the second
largest donor outside of the united
states
as a whole and those same world health
organization bill gates whom you said
were the best at handling these kinds of
crises throughout the history of mankind
told the world through twitter that it
couldn't be transmitted from human to
human contact
let's go to bill gates he looks uh he
looks like he looks like an angry muppet
he's animated
you know it seems i was going to say he
looks like an albino gecko
well sweater i know we're going to talk
about vaccines they screen tested him
for geico commercial pakistan
but if we get to this point that we're
talking about bill with testing
and and having enough contact tracing
which you say you know we should be able
to get to these
things if we use your micro chipping
bill gates yeah we'll see
let's make sure i bring this up so i
have it right because it'll check me if
i say microchip
so first off of course he said that
china did a good job he trashed the
united states response he said that the
world health organization is the best
organization in the world at dealing
with this stuff
really the organization that said it
couldn't be transmitted through human
and human contact
new windows 2000 inventing print
and then he uh said that we had no
national tracking system so he praised
south korea
is anyone does anyone else get
absolutely terrified when we talk about
contact racing like people people are
worried about like
it's like i don't wanna oh my god on my
iphone i don't want to accept cookies
someone
sent me i better put a sticky note on it
contact tracing so the south korean
government can dox me
sure sign me up right people as long as
it as long as it
keeps me from experiencing all right
i'll give you all my rights or what what
is it the 80
that are asymptomatic or whatever the
number is it's incredibly high reg you
can fact check me on that i think it's
uh i've heard anywhere from 25 to 40
percent
um he's been pushing a nationwide
shutdown of everything and then what he
wanted to install let me bring this up
from the scientific american
you guys can bring it up contact tracing
die
into children so you can bring it up as
an overlay because people can see it it
looks i mean look at that it looks like
a chip if it functions like a chip
really it doesn't matter if you're
saying a chip or not going into the skin
it's on the research stock here
you see this yeah that looks like a chip
and videos were removed for fetching
something like ah you know bill gates
wants us like a tracking chip
like it's a contact tell me that doesn't
look like a chip yeah
we're crying out loud so this is i want
to make sure that i have this right hey
actually can we bring up reg the
research bandit can you give me a quick
recap of uh i remember contact tracing
die and it looking very much like a chip
and it was specifically to provide
information this is what i remember
uh specifically providing information so
that people could know which children
had been vaccinated
right and uh you know could could uh
star in the next episode of black mirror
reg
yeah it's it's uh essentially an under
the skin
tattoo and it seems to make sense
insofar as that you think well then you
don't
need to carry around your vaccination
records everywhere with you
but then the problem is that you have
this global system of control and
tracking people yeah
yeah well it's a small price to pay for
not having to carry paperwork
yeah you know because you're good with
convenience take a picture of them and
keep them in your phone
it would be brought to bear and they'd
have very clear advice on things like
testing prioritization
uh you know so that they that is a
deep set of skills where they're you
know getting input
uh from all the states but the you know
in the entire world that's the best
group of people
uh there's an opportunity here for them
to help with testing prioritization and
i you know i hope they'll seize it agree
with sanjay right now i i know that um
i'm also confused what the hell he's
looking at other countries
you you don't want to look too much in
the room if you're walking windows
what went right or what went wrong there
we should be listening to doctors like
bill gates
yes exactly yeah well no bill gates is
safe because everything he says goes
along with the world health organization
including taiwan what trusted source and
it cannot be transmitted through human
to human contact here's the thing do you
know how
do you know um do you know what my
qualifications
are what's up personally in dispensing
medical advice please give it to me
about the same as bill gates oh yeah
they're right almost exactly
comparable yeah right all right so
neither are qualified except you're not
responsible for vista
the pcr machines activated to do those
tests so
uh you know play some places
uh listen to what was being said in
january and did those things and some
some did not hold on a second there's
also a lot of things we could have done
in terms of innovation
way before the epidemic showed up wait
hold on a second you know also some
places listen to
them in january he's talking about the
world health organization this matters
this is what matters
the most about this the left because
they have an echo chamber here right and
they don't
have you seen by the way has anyone seen
them provide any sources at all by the
way
sanjay gupta jogging and short pants
doesn't count no okay
they haven't shown any sources
whatsoever and just now they're
completely unaccountable so they never
get called on their
they never have to correct it and bill
gates right now just said we could have
been following the advice
in january in january the world health
organization to whom you are the second
largest donor outside of the united
states as a whole
and those same world health organization
bill gates whom you said
were the best at handling these kinds of
crises throughout the history of mankind
told the world through twitter that it
couldn't be transmitted from human to
human contact
so if we were to follow their advice
bill
what would we have done mr gates there's
a lot of trials out in various countries
the list of things being tried
is very long uh the one i'd have to say
i'm the
most optimistic about is taking
antibodies
and manufacturing those you know finding
the best antibody that
a human is noticed that bill gates
speaks exactly like
trump but because he's a nerd he'll give
him more respect
there are a lot of things let me just
say exactly what he just said is donald
trump
there are a lot of things that we could
do and we're looking into more
things uh the one that's most promising
is the antibodies
and we're looking at the best
antibodies just because he has glasses
and hasn't been laid in half a century
we're supposed to respect his opinion
more
but you know hey we're here to solve
problems this is the most important tool
the most urgent tool mankind has to
invest
yeah i mean that's why we're spending so
much time talking about vaccines but
once we get to that point there's seven
billion roughly by the way the planet
assuming that we get a vaccine and
obviously i'm i'm pro-vaccine for covid
but that also you're assuming that
everyone is going to take it
or we'll want to take it flu vaccines
every year that we have
there's this gigantic number of people
that just don't do it including myself
what's the number of people who take flu
vaccines per year red can probably i
think it's like
it's under 20 percent i would i would
bet it's really low i think it's about
older people right people's susceptible
system
stuff like that would do it but
everybody else i can't whatever
but why are they again moving the goal
posts now it's about the vaccine we
can't do anything until the vaccine
so here's the thing that's really we
need to be clear about with bill gates
you can bring this up as an overlay he
thinks we should have a permanent
lockdown of everything until we have the
vaccine no absolutely not well i
know don't i don't know i'm saying i'm
arguing what's going to come out
a billion dollars is like you know guys
don't worry yeah
don't worry i'll be safe yeah he's going
to be sitting there with his harem
we're all in this together guys
everybody's out mad maxing it around
i mean gerald's favorite the cast of
cats
[Laughter]
really what i mean is he's gonna have
idris elba and the clones that he could
afford to make
oh my gosh in a hot tub
actually just it is flat hotel gates in
a hot tub with mr mistoffelees
from cats i mean you know the names i
don't
someone just asked will there ever be a
home test kid for covenant are they
are they idiots it's there already so
there's already a home antibody test i
think it's from quest if i'm not
mistaken
i think it's from quest labs i'm sure
what was that that was just probably i
think that was the
number of the percentage of people that
get the uh
vaccine what was the number it hovers
around forty percent looks like forty
forty okay that's higher than i thought
i was wrong west diagnostics who came up
with a
home no a home antibody test because i
think it's uh pathology
there you go there it is antibody test
so that's an antibody test not just a
covid test but that tells you you've
ever actually had the disease and then i
think it's if i'm not mistaken pathology
laboratories i'm not entirely sure
uh maybe it's lab core they have um you
know quick testing stations set up in
walgreens uh in a lot of walgreens
these are dumb questions now here's the
challenge though right now and i know
all of us are not paying attention we're
all trying to see that area in question
circulating
that's the only thing we're looking for
so here is the challenge
four i don't know if we can set a timer
for two minutes
we are not to talk we are just to listen
to cnn
and look for errors the promo code is
quarantined because they're gonna go to
commercials
for two minutes we will watch after
which we'll see if there's anything to
actually verify confirm is correct or
fact check but for two minutes
all right you know germany for example
has done things well but they did have
the benefit that they saw italy
being overwhelmed and their exposure
came after italy so they were able to
respond
but now the exposure in sweden and
germany were about
at the same time if you look uh
at the ihme uh which is a group that we
uh fun if you look at their forecast
while you had chris marion earlier
uh you look at the death rate
uh in sweden versus germany that they
forecast
it's way higher up in sweden and so
you know somebody can decide a
politician if if that's what really
happens was it worth it
um you know that's what this is all
about is if you open activity x
uh you know are you willing to accept a
somewhat higher
uh health burden because of that sweden
uh you know they made their decision
they seemed happy with their decision
but they are forecast to have
substantially higher death rate than
uh most other countries one of the
things in your paper that i that i
thought was really particularly
interesting were all the things that
we need to learn about the virus like if
it is weather dependent how many people
never get symptoms but are contagious
what symptoms mean you should get tested
i mean there's so much we still
don't know about this
yeah there are many countries uh
where the epidemic is not nearly as
intense
as we would expect and so is it just a
delayed effect is there something about
the vaccines they get in their youth you
know people think this
bcg vaccine might you know be a helpful
thing
we don't know and so we have to assume
it's going to be as bad in all those
countries
uh you know in the southern hemisphere
you have brazil
australia south africa cases so they're
not completely immune even though the
force of infection may be less
when you you uh famously talked about
preparing for
a reality
we're out of it reg the research bandit
please bring up sweden and the fact that
they
they they failed to protect and
acknowledge their infirm and their older
people with their nursing homes they had
a similar situation to new york
and if you look at sweden sweden is
actually middle of the pack compared to
europe he specifically took germany and
sweden because he tried to take
a country that had very severe measures
and also took an early stance and
frankly they have different demographics
uh comparing it directly to sweden which
is directly middle of the pack it would
be an accurate comparison as well would
be sweden versus belgium sweden versus
france sweden versus uk sweden versus
spain italy i don't know why he only
picked germany because it's the one
country the one country i guess in
western civilization that is actually
doing significantly better than the
united states and that's because of
a very homogenous culture an
authoritarian government who's very
comfortable with removing people's
private rights
and they suck here's the thing germany
good on good on you you got coronavirus
right but when it comes to world wars
you're responsible for still all of them
if we're keeping a tally
so it's a trade-off just bring up the
deaths per million and look
at sweden they didn't take any measures
at all which we are not even advocating
and they're far better off than some
countries who took very strict measures
not saying they're the best not saying
they're the worst but that's actually
the strongest counter argument to what
bill gates is saying because
if sweden were definitively the best
then we would know we'd be basing it off
that data if it were definitively the
worst
he would have the best case here that he
could make instead it's right
it's it's like starsky and hutch where
they were trying to find out if a guy
was named big because he was small
ironic and he's 5 10 which is just about
average
that's sweden hey if you enjoyed this
show subscriber hit the notification
i'm cov it's cold in here so i'm
covering i'm covering my nips
hit all notifications on the
notification bell because uh apparently
notification
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
look at their video what they're playing
in boxes does that was happening
quarterback here
their videos playing in boxes you should
click one of them
maybe one of them's a mystery box
could cut glass with these things